today the mattwell show a reporter for
the daily wire quits the company and
publicly accuses some of our
personalities me and Michael Knowles of
being too divisive and mean when it
comes to the gender issue also Chuck
Schumer calls for the for Fox News to
stop Tucker Carlson from releasing more
January 6 footage apparently it's a
threat to our democracy if we're given
more information about what happened on
January 6th El Salvador's harsh
treatment of violent cartel members
comes under scrutiny from squeamish
Americans the homeland security
secretary refuses to admit that there's
a crisis on our border it's just a
challenge he says and a Washington Post
journalist complains that monitoring JK
Rowling for evidence of transphobia is
exhausting work she has exhausted all of
that and more today on the Matt Walsh
show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
yeah I'm on the road right now as you
can see I'm in a hotel room and one
thing about uh being on the road is that
it can be very difficult to maintain a a
healthy diet and healthy habits while
while you're on the road while you're on
the go if you're living A busy life
that's why I'm a huge fan of balance of
nature balance of nature fruits and
veggies are the best way to make sure
you're getting essential nutritional
ingredients every single day their
products are 100 Whole Food balance of
nature uses a cold vacuum process that
preserves the natural phytonutrients in
whole fruits and vegetables and that
encapsulates them for easy consumption
battle nature sent a bunch of their
products down to the office for our team
to try and everyone loves them they are
delicious as well as being very healthy
as well go to balanceofnature.com and
use promo code Walsh for 35 off your
first order as a preferred customer
that's balanceofnature.com promo code
walls for 35 off their first preferred
order today
yesterday I learned that one of my
colleagues the daily wire had decided to
leave the company and this is not
exactly breaking news people come and go
all the time as is the case of any large
and growing company what made this
unique is that I learned about her
resignation from a blog post which was
then picked up by Outlets like mediaite
and the Daily Dot and Amplified of
course by employees at Media Matters
where she in part blames me for her
decision to quit the company Christina
buttons was her name she's a reporter
hired just a few months ago to cover
issues related to gender ideology
especially the abuse of children that
happens in the name of gender ideology I
appreciated the work that she did when
she worked for the daily wire and never
had any issues with her as far as I was
aware anyway and then she tweeted this
on Tuesday morning
I'm leaving the daily wire I worked hard
getting the facts right and using
precise language because of the heated
nature of the gender debate with so much
at stake while their pundits dumped
gasoline all over it for entertainment
and clicks now company that's wheat is a
link to a blog post with a picture of
herself along with me and uh Michael
Knowles off to the side there now
in the post she explains that our
inflammatory and divisive rhetoric has
driven her away she writes in part quote
when the documentary what is a woman was
released in 2022 I thought it was a
brilliant commentary on the state of our
culture Matt Walsh didn't insult his
interviewees but instead let them
embarrass themselves with deeply
incoherent attempts to answer a question
any first grader should be able to
answer even my liberal parents love the
movie so the daily wire approached me
with the opportunity to write
exclusively on transgender issues with
an emphasis on pediatric gender medicine
I accept it but recent videos and posts
have weakened my confidence and their
commitment to this message on
Valentine's Day Matt Walsh did a segment
on a show about transgender influencer
Dylan Mulvaney that has now been viewed
by millions
quote you are weird artificial you are
manufactured lifeless you are unearthly
and Eerie you are like some kind of
human deep fake Walsh said everyone who
looks at you will see something pitiable
and bizarre Walsh has defended these
statements as a good strategy because he
says they rallied the conservative base
he adds that the goal is not to convince
the other side but to defeat humiliate
and demoralize his opponents this
triggered a race to the bottom with
other social media personas one-upping
each other to see who can take more
extreme stances
she goes on to explain that there are uh
people who she calls transsexuals who
are not ideologues she claims and who
she says uh you know are they know that
they're not actually the opposite sex
even if that's how they identify
and she worries that my quote-unquote
Hardline stands
maybe not only alienating them but also
fueling a quote sudden Deluge of animus
towards transsexuals she continues to
quote I can only assume that the
enthusiasm generated by Walsh's
hard-line position encouraged another
colleague of mine Michael Knowles to
make a controversial statement at this
year's conservative political action
conference CPAC as a journalist I have
to believe that there are reachable
centers including moderate liberals who
are uncomfortable with gender ideology
but who have been insulated from serious
coverage of this medical Scandal winning
over hearts and Minds is difficult
enough without inflammatory statements
such as transgenderism must be
eradicated from public life there's a
critical distinction between speaking
truth and being tactless between
sticking to the facts and sticking it to
the libs I'm keenly aware of the
distinction between factual reporting
and opinion as a journalist and reporter
I dedicated my days and nights to
meticulously surveying data scouring the
primary literature and choosing the best
words to accurately convey the truth but
such painstaking attention to details
rendered meaningless when the company's
Flagship entertainers and personalities
speak impulsively and deploy divisive
rhetoric for entertainment and clicks
this is not a game we cannot afford to
make these issues overtly partisan the
bodies minds and lives of children are
being permanently damaged and everyone
not just reporters and journalists has a
duty to approach this issue with the
seriousness it demands
now I admit that outside of her articles
on daily wire I didn't follow
Christina's work very closely and so I
didn't know that in recent weeks she had
also been on Twitter accusing uh those
uh who are too far to the right as far
as she is concerned on trans issues of
transphobia using that term exactly
calling people transphobes now if I'd
known that this was a sort of person who
unironically accuses people of
transphobia I would not have been too
surprised by what happened yesterday and
even without knowing that I'm still not
very surprised because as we've seen
over the last several weeks there has
been what we might call a kind of great
sorting among the critics of gender
ideology those who are not willing to go
as far as is needed and to say
everything that needs to be said
have been weeding themselves out and
this is just the latest in in that line
in that procession
they're turning against their own allies
doing it in public thereby intentionally
giving ammunition to the very people
they were supposed to be fighting
against
there's a reason why Media Matters picks
us up I mean just as a general rule by
the way if you are supposed to be
opposing the left or opposing them on
any of these issues and you do or say
anything that Media Matters finds useful
then that's a pretty good indication
that uh you screwed up
but they do this to their own side
because they were never fully on our
side to begin with and and that's I
think the crucial Point here I'm not
going to waste a lot of time on the
personal side of this uh except to say
that I worked in the same building as
this person right across the hall from
her
um if I'm not traveling I'm I'm in the
office essentially from dawn to dusk and
sometimes longer so should have an ample
opportunity to walk across the room and
talk to me about her concerns could have
had a private conversation as colleagues
and alleged allies in the fight against
gender ideology could have done that
but instead she chose to say nothing to
me at all and take her grievances to the
public
in doing so she she not only questioned
my Approach and my strategy but also my
integrity and sincerity same for Michael
Knowles
questioning it on his end too accusing
us of being mainly interested in clicks
and entertainment and insinuating that
we're uh we're not taking the issue
seriously enough
this is ironic given that she made these
accusations in a blog post where she
used
both my name and my picture and Michael
Knowles's name and picture to get clicks
and at the end of her resignation she
even solicits solicits personal
donations
so it's like Matt Walsh who's only in it
for the money by the way if you agree
with my complaints about Matt Walsh
please consider giving me money
it's a bold sales pitch I will admit
we'll see if it pays off
but the personal insults are not my
primary concerning I realize I'm a bit
old-fashioned you know I was raised to
always speak directly to people if I
have an issue with them I was also
taught that I I shouldn't needlessly
burn Bridges with people who have helped
me and may be able to help me in the
future
I mean I can remember being 17 years old
and working at the local pizza place and
uh and I was getting ready to quit
and my dad told me even then make sure
you don't burn the bridge don't want to
burn the bridge with the pizza place you
never know when you're going to need
them again
but these days many people feel that
whenever they quit a job they have to
nail their 95 Theses to the door
publicly outlining every single thing
they didn't like about the place
they do that in the Forum now of uh it's
not so much a thesis on the door but
it's in the form of a tick tock video or
you know a sub stack or something like
that
I would say that this is this is not
only improper and an unfair way to treat
people who've helped you professionally
but also just a very bad career move
that you are destined to regret in the
future
but that's just me I suppose
much more important point
is that
again this is someone who's just the
latest in a line of people who are
supposedly on our side in this fight and
yet have turned against those of us who
they feel are too extreme or too harsh
or whatever
as far as that goes I think there are
there there are uh a couple of crucial
takeaways here
I've already explained in strenuous
detail
why I believe it's not only morally
Justified but also a good strategy to be
blunt and more aggressive I don't need
to belabor the point any more than I
already have
um except to say that if you if you
think that it's possible to win a
cultural battle and bring about a
massive social change
while also being exclusively polite and
Mild tempered and focused on compromise
then you have never studied history
any history I have to assume because
that's not how this works
or has ever worked
anywhere
every social movement needs its
Frontline combatants it's a it's uh
Street Fighters you know it's people who
are willing to get their hands dirty so
if you think that I'm a confrontational
jerk maybe you're right
but the confrontational jerk Community
okay serves an important purpose you
need us whether you like it or not no
cultural battle can be won or has ever
been won anywhere in the world without
us
now not everyone needs to adopt our
approach or should adopt it you see this
doesn't go the other way
I'm not out here saying well nobody
should ever be polite nobody should be
nicer no one should be more gentle I
don't say that as I've said many times I
believe in a in in and I I embrace A
diversity of tactics
so the problem isn't that these gentler
and more squeamish people aren't
adopting our approach is that they think
everyone should adopt their approach
and they're wrong about that and that
that is also why if you notice
uh on the left
they don't have this conversation have
you noticed that they never have this
conversation so on the right we're
constantly stuck in every day it has
it's it's another version of the same
debate are we being too mean are we
being too mean to them is it does this
too mean have you noticed on the left
they have never once had that debate
amongst themselves they never talk about
that they're not worried about that
now they might have a debate when
there's some people on the left like
Bill Maher or whoever who's who might
say I think we're being too crazy I
think that some of the things we're
advocating for are insane and and we
need to pull back from that because
we're alienating but there's a few
people on the left will make that point
but if they can all agree that they're
right about something
then they will never ever even consider
the possibility that they're being too
mean
why
well because they're smarter than a lot
of the people that are supposedly on our
side they just are they realize that
it's just it
they realize that it's effective
you know it's a it is effective to be
blunt and direct and that you need that
approach it's effective it's an
effective strategy
and also it's morally Justified if
you're in the right they think they're
in the right they're not but they think
they are
and they tell themselves they are
and so they tell themselves that they
have righteous anger and they're
expressing it
we actually are in the right so our
anger is righteous and should be
expressed
but there's another problem too which I
think runs much deeper
and this is becoming clear and clearer
by the day uh to me that you know the
the fracturing in the movement right now
is not driven primarily by a
disagreement over tactics okay rather
it's driven by a fundamental
disagreement over the issue itself
there are many critics of gender
ideology who it turns out
are not actually critics of gender
ideology
not fully anyway
okay they want the kids to be left alone
they want to protect the Integrity of
female sports maybe they're concerned
about privacy in the bathrooms
but when You Dig Down Deeper you
discover that they aren't willing to
attack the concept of transgenderism
itself they recoil at some of its
consequences
they protest against some of its
implications
but they're not willing to wage an
assault against the very roots of this
evil that's why they were so appalled by
what Michael Knowles said
okay it's not that he it's not that he
used the term eradicate that's not the
issue actually
it's that he identified the concept as
the UN the concept of transgenderism as
the underlying problem
he pointed to the roots rather than the
branches
and that's what they don't like
this is the dividing line This is the
fault line that runs through the
movement and separates one side from the
other there are those who want to prune
the branches
which means you're going to always be
pruning them because the branches aren't
going anywhere
and then there are those of us who want
to uproot the entire tree
and yes uprooting the tree is more
dramatic it's more startling
it's Messier
it may even be upsetting to some of
those precious centrists in the middle
now it might be a little upsetting to
them
they might look at that they're taking
the whole tree out
that seems extreme to me do we really
need to do this yeah they might they
might it might it might make them a
little upset
but it's the only way to win
okay if you're not doing that you're not
even actually trying to win
all you are doing is attempting weekly
to mitigate some of the damage but you
are not doing anything to address the
thing that is actually causing the
damage
we can either eradicate the cancer
or we can continue treating its symptoms
until the cancer wins
and if you're not willing to go after
the cancer itself
then we aren't even on the same side
so it's time for everyone to actually
decide here the time of choosing
whose side are you actually on
because there is no middle here
you have to choose
now let's get to our five headlines
you know having your private life
exposed for others to see was one
something only celebrities had to worry
about but in an era where everyone is
online then everyone becomes a public
figure what's changed think about
everything that you've browsed
everything you've searched for watched
tweeted now imagine all of that data
being crawled through collected
aggregated by Third parties into a
permanent public record which is your
record
that's why to keep my data private when
I go online I turn to expressvpn when I
use expressvpn my online presence is
anonymized making it difficult for
anyone to track my online activity and
it couldn't be easier to set up as well
all you got to do is just tap one button
on your phone or computer and uh and
you're protected it's that easy
expressvpn works on all your devices
your phone your tablet your computer
whether you're wherever you are in the
world whatever you're doing expressvpn
can and will protect you if you believe
that your data is your business secure
yourself with the number one rated VPN
on the market visit expressvpn.com Walsh
you get three extra months for free
that's exp
resvpn.com Walsh today expressvpn.com
Walsh to learn more
Tucker Carlson of course began airing
unreleased footage from the uh from
January 6 this week and it's been very
upsetting for Democrats and for the
media uh you know they they want us all
to talk about and focus on January 6 but
only on certain very very carefully
curated details of that day
uh remember these are the media and
Democrats they are reality curators
now they do a fair amount of outright
lying about things
but most of the misdirection is about
curating
reality like taking certain bits of what
is real and curating in a certain way to
present a picture that's that's uh
either not the full picture or is
completely wrong and and uh and
misleading
um what they don't want
is and so because they're curators uh
what they don't want is just a a you
know a full it's this this
full stream of information being
released to the public they don't want
that
they don't want information that they
can't control being released to the
public and that's what they're very
afraid about especially when it comes to
this and that's why Chuck Schumer took
to the floor of the Senate
um yesterday to very explicitly call for
Carlson to be censored
and and for the footage to be suppressed
and he wasn't hinting at it or anything
he was directly calling for for it from
the floor of the Senate let's listen
so many others who were here in the
capital and millions and millions of
Americans are just furious
with Tucker Carlson and Kevin McCarthy
today
and he's going to come back tonight with
another segment
Fox News should tell him not to
Fox News Rupert Murdoch tell Carlson not
to run a second segment of Lies you know
it's a lie you've admitted it's a lie
and speaker McCarthy is every bit as
culpable
as Mr Carlson
speaker McCarthy's decision
to share security footage with Fox
looked like a mistake from the very
beginning
but after last night
it looks like a disaster
speaker McCarthy has played a
treacherous a treacherous game
by catering to the hard right
he's enabled the big lie
and has further eroded away at our
precious democracy last night millions
of Americans tuned into one of the most
shameful hours we have ever seen on
cable television
with contempt for the facts
disregarded the risks and knowing full
well he was lying lying to his audience
Fox News host Tucker Carlson ran a
lengthy segment last night arguing the
January 6 Capital attack
was not a violent insurrection
by diving deep into the Waters of
conspiracy and cherry picking from
thousands of hours of security footage
Mr Carlson told the bold-faced lie that
the capital attack which we all saw with
their own eyes
was somehow not an attack at all
he tried to argue it was nothing more
than a peaceful sightseeing tour can you
imagine I urge Fox News to order Carlson
to cease propagating the big lie on his
Network I can't imagine that personally
all right turn him off that's fine I
know I I can't imagine I can't imagine
anyone in the media claiming that a riot
was mostly peaceful I can't imagine that
this is the first time I I this is this
is uh totally unprecedented
well I'll tell you what is unprecedented
is uh
or very nearly unprecedented I can't
think of another example
where you have a a sitting United States
Senator
on the floor of the Senate directly
calling for a member of the media to be
censored and suppressed calling on his
employer to stop him from doing a new a
News segment
has it ever happened before
if it has happened it's not it's uh
it's a rare occurrence
and it is ironically a much bigger much
greater attack on our democracy than
anything that Chuck Schumer is
complaining about
what's an attack on our democracy a a a
a news figure news personality about an
opinion host
giving his opinion about an event and
also releasing footage that we can all
see like is that the attack on our
democracy or is it a United States
Senator
directly using his power as a senator
and his platform to call for that person
to be censored and suppressed
it's also if you're if you are concerned
about how you know what the audience
will think when they see the January 6
footage
and you're and if you're a Democrat and
you're worried that they'll see it and
they'll be sympathetic to uh to the
rioters and others
well the best way to make sure that
they're sympathetic and the best way to
to confirm all of their suspicions is to
do exactly what Chuck Schumer's do
I mean if I didn't know any better I
would think these people are they're
trying to provoke another
as much as they as much as they as much
as they pretend to fret about there's
going to be another January 6th
but we knows that they would love
nothing more they would love nothing
more than for there to be another one
that would be uh that would send them
into it almost to orgasmic Delight if
there was another one
I mean just just look how much mileage
they got out of the first
so this is what's unprecedented
trying to
suppress footage
I also think it's funny when he uh
complains about Cherry Picked it's
cherry-picked well yeah it's a one-hour
news program uh you can only fit so much
footage into it so yes cherry picking as
in picking the parts that are the most
relevant and interesting and and that
are the most revealing and the most
newsworthy and releasing those
hey it's Tucker Carlson cannot air 40
000 hours of uncut footage during his
one hour news program
but speaking of Cherry Picked
what what about said this is the
unreleased footage remember this is the
unreleased footage from January 6. there
has been a little bit of footage that's
been released
but what about the people that released
it
is that not cherry-picked
what about all the many uh January 6th
committees and hearings and the footage
that they released during during uh
those charades
was that not also cherry pickle of
course it was
it was Cherry Picked to support a
certain narrative and now Tucker
Carlson's coming along and he's picking
different footage
to shed diff a different kind of light
on the event and that's what they're
obviously worried about is how it
interferes with the narrative
how can they be lies anyway
so are you accusing him of doctoring the
footage
maybe that's where they'll go next I
wouldn't be surprised
it's been doctored
but right now they're not even claiming
that Mrs actual footage see it for
yourself the footage of that we played
yesterday of Jacob chansley the
so-called Q Anon Shaman being escorted
through the building
okay where's the LIE there what part of
that is a lie was was he not escorted
through the building or are our eyes
deceiving us is this uh some sort of
special effects
is is did Doug Carlson deploy deceptive
editing to make it seem that way
well okay then then release whatever
whatever other context is needed
to make it clear that it wasn't what it
seems like release that let us see that
if the capitol police officers were not
escorting this guy through the building
as if he was taking a sightseeing tour
if that's not what they were doing then
what were they doing
and if there's if it was cherry-picked
then show us the rest
have you noticed that too that they they
say it's cherry-picked it's not the full
story okay well then
whatever footage Carlson released if
there's more footage
that would create a context that would
totally change you know our our opinion
and perception of of what Carlson shows
then release that footage but you notice
they're they're not
what they're what they're doing instead
is just trying to suppress the footage
rather than releasing more footage
to give us more context
and I think that tells you everything
you need to know the White House was
asked about this as well and here's what
Karen Jean pair said about it
last night Tucker Carlson Cherry Picked
a video surveillance from the January
6th Insurrection severely downplaying
the event of that day he said the mob
was orderly and meek and that they were
tourists instead of insurrectionists
what's your response to Carlson and to
speaker Kevin McCarthy who granted him
access to that video
um anybody who watched that video would
strongly disagree anybody who watched
that video uh in a
with their own eyes in a real way and
saw what happened on that day would
would disagree with what was just stated
the president has been very clear
January 6 was the worst attack on our
democracy since the Civil War and we
should be focused on making sure that
never happens again
and so we are certainly uh we agree I
noticed a minority leader and uh and uh
Senator Schumer have already said this
and would hope that keeping the capital
and Congress safe and secure remains uh
Congressional leaders number one goal
and that should be our focus and that
should be what should be considered here
um and again it was one of the doctor's
Days of our democracy and all you have
to do is watch those videos and see how
horrific it was you see how sad it was
see an attack on the capitol which
should not be happening in 2020 and we
got to get down to the bottom of what
happened again it was an attack on our
democracy and I'll just leave it there
so if she makes no attempts
to even seem sincere in anything that
she says
you know very clearly reading sometimes
literally reading from a script
well this was an attack on our democracy
the worst attack since the Civil War
was it really because you know the Civil
War
a total of
600 000 people were killed it totally
changed the the course of the nation I
mean nothing is the same after after the
Civil War 600 000 Americans dead you
know about 300 000 on both sides
so it's an actual
War actual physical War being fought in
the United States
um and this was an event
January 6 rather was an event that
happened over the course of a couple
hours in DC
um the only person who was directly
killed that day was one of the Riders
and uh
and then it was over and that's it
oh yeah I mean exactly the same
of course
all right I'm a little uh late to this
story but here's the financial times
it says on the remote planes of the Las
chicas volcano the strongman leader of
El Salvador has built a mega prison that
is supposed to become the world's
biggest by population and the most
overcrowded by Design
the president proudly opened the new
house for 40 000 prisoners last month
where gang members will be sent to live
for decades to pay for their alleged
crimes the vast penal experiment if it
reaches full capacity will be unrivaled
in the scale of its incarceration a
facility that could accommodate
two-thirds of Germany's total prison
population in one place
but if the presidency is through his
plans the uh the prison the prison will
also have another unique and chilling
feature it will set records for
deliberately designed overcrowding
according to Financial Times analysis of
the complex using satellite imagery if
it reaches the 40 000 capacity
advertised by the government each inmate
will have just 0.6 square meters within
shared cells according to Ft
calculations that is a fraction of what
is expected for Humane incarceration and
less than half the minimum required
under EU law to transport mid-size
cattle by Road
there's been a lot of footage of this uh
of this this prison that's been
circulating online and you can see it's
a very you know if you've got hundreds
and hundreds of inmates that are being
escorted through the prison they're
being made to kneel on the ground uh
it's they're being treated well they're
being treated like prisoners if you can
imagine and I understand it's very
shocking for those of us in the modern
United States to see prisoners being
treated like prisoners
my God they're treating these prisoners
like some sort of prisoners
so it's shocking for us
um when we see footage like this here's
a here's a report from CNN with some of
the footages a warning some of the
images you're about to see you might
find disturbing
[Music]
what you're looking at is a glossing
professionally shot so promotional video
of El Salvador's new giant prison
it shows thousands of alleged gangsters
being taken to a jail so big it can host
40 000 people
and that the government says is the
largest in the Americas
El Salvador is a country with a huge
prison population because of the
presence of two of the largest criminal
organizations in the world MS-13 and
Barrio 18.
last year the country's president
naibukele launched a new National
Emergency law to fight the gangs
the LED to tens of thousands of arrests
do you see the footage
shocking footage terribly shocking and
it is terrible yeah you know I would uh
this is overboard I mean I would never
treat violent gang members this way
I was just kidding of course I mean this
is uh you know what this is this is this
is actually Justice
that's what Justice looks like
and again I know maybe it's surprising
to those of us the United States in a
comfortable modern Western Civilization
that also happens to be decaying and
falling apart uh and in part because of
our rampant crime that's destroying all
of our cities
but still it might be surprising to us
to see that uh prisons are not supposed
to be comfortable
they are supposed to be the kinds of
places that you really don't want to go
to
supposed to be a punishment
you're supposed to suffer when you're in
prison
that's what punishment is meant to do it
is meant to cause suffering not just
suffering for its own sake but for a
purpose
um
and the purpose ultimately is justice
but there is no such thing as Justice if
you are not causing suffering to
evildoers
it that doesn't exist
and the reaction though to this El
Salvador prison story is it's
interesting because you got lots of
people who constantly complain about you
know non-violent offenders being locked
in prison in this country
um
and yet they're still complaining about
this even though these guys are cartel
members they belong to Central American
Drug gangs okay these are as violent and
dangerous as it gets
these are not non-violent offenders
these are these are the guys who will
kidnap you and cut your head off and
leave your your headless body in the
middle of the street and throw your head
into a bag with all the other severed
heads that's that's these guys that's
what they do
um these are the guys who will murder
your children
okay these are the guys that will kill
your entire family without even thinking
about it
and you're concerned that they are being
treated too harshly
now this actually makes sense when you
understand something that the people who
complain about this sort of thing
most of them are not bleeding heart
liberals now they're leftist but the
bleeding heart liberal stereotypes
almost entirely a fantasy
um they don't have bleeding hearts okay
they don't I mean if we showed them this
same footage but we told them that all
the prisoners were convicted of being uh
what are we talking that all the
prisoners are convicted transphobes
well then then they probably complain
the treatment's not harsh enough
then they would say oh it's only it's a
0.6 square meters that you're giving
them that much they're transphobes
so they don't have an overabundance of
compassion and sympathy no the issue is
this
uh first they're beholden to Identity
politics obviously which means that
cartel gang bangers from Central America
well they're victims because they belong
to a victim class as do most prisoners
United States that's part of it the
other part is that
is that they they don't believe in free
will
okay and that plays a big role and it it
very rarely does it come up explicitly
when we're talking about criminal
justice issues and so-called Criminal
Justice Reform but that actually is what
is what lies underneath a lot of this is
that the people that are advocating for
quote unquote Criminal Justice Reform
whether in this country or in El
Salvador anywhere else they they don't
believe in free will
um which means they they don't want
prisoners to be harshly punished because
they don't think that prisoners are and
criminals are responsible for anything
they do
that's the point for them
if they look at these guys and yeah
they're they're violent gang members
cartel members they'll cut your head off
they'll cut your children's heads off
but they're not it's it's not their
fault they're not resp they don't make
that choice they are there are already
prisoners of circumstance and it's
circumstance and environment and all of
that that determines what they do they
have no agency over their own actions
um nobody does
according to the left
so they reject the concept of Free Will
which means that really any form of of
punishment is cruel and unusual because
you're punishing people for something
that they didn't that they had no that
they didn't actually do they didn't
choose to do it
and that's nonsense obviously Free Will
is not only a free will exist but it's
one of the most self-evident realities
in the universe
but that is what they think of course
this is not consistently applied as I
said if they if they saw that video and
we told them these were convicted
transphobes they'd be okay with it so
even though they don't believe in Free
Will and they believe that we're certain
victims of circumstance and that
everything we do is we're programmed to
do it and so forth
um they they don't apply that equally
and so if they accuse you of being a
bigot or transphob or homophobe then
they they want you to suffer the
consequences for that so you are guilty
of that you're responsible for that
however if you're a gang member in El
Salvador and you cut somebody's head off
you're not responsible for that so this
is it's not consistent it's not coherent
obviously but
um and one thing that we know about the
left is that whatever their principles
are uh they they never apply them
consistently ever I mean their number
one principle is don't apply principles
consistently
but that is what is uh that that's
that's the underlying issue thing issue
here I think
all right
let's see
one other thing before we get to the uh
comment section
uh
well maybe two so Homeland Security
secretary Alejandro mayorkas was on CNN
as well where he was um asked whether
the Border crisis is in fact a crisis
and here's what he says
many of your opponents call it aboard a
crisis do you consider it a crisis in
the Biden Administration Christian the
the the issues that we have are
extraordinarily diverse you know I spoke
about extreme weather events I spoke
about cyber security you and I have now
exchanged about the threat of adverse
nation states that seek to infringe on R
and other countries sovereignty you know
20 years ago when our department was
created it was the foreign terrorists we
now have the challenge of a domestic
violent extremists when we speak about
the Border we have to put it in context
that this is not a challenge and it is
indeed a challenge not a challenge
exclusive to the United States you know
Chile just deployed its military to its
border Colombia has 2.5 million
Venezuelans within its borders Costa
Rica's population is increasingly
Nicaraguan we are seeing a movement of
people through throughout the hemisphere
and quite frankly throughout the world
that is historic
it's not a crisis it's a challenge
it's a challenge you see so it's always
interesting
to see where they where they uh
Democrats become suddenly you know they
become suddenly very cautious in in the
way that they describe things and they
don't want to engage in Hyperbole and so
they'll be very careful we don't call it
a crisis it's a challenge
um so they do that on this particular
issue
so on this issue it's a it is a a
challenge not a crisis
but when you have I I don't know the
examples are endless when you have
parents showing up at school board
meetings you know angry that there's
pornography in the in in the library
that's a CR that we can describe as a
credit it's a domestic terrorism crisis
and the crisis is not the pornography
but that the parents are upset about it
however when you've got millions of
people pouring into this country our
borders being erased
um not a crisis just a challenge sure
all right so one other quick thing I did
I did a segment several days ago I think
it was a daily cancellation where I
talked about asexuals and in particular
I was responding to a profile of an
asexual in the New York Times The
Washington Post or one of these Outlets
they're all the same and they told us
about an asexual person and they even
introduced us to the asexual stuffed
animals
and uh and they gave us the names of the
stuffed animals too
um and that's the kind of thing Taylor
Made For The Daily cancellation I mean
when a mainstream Outlet puts something
like that out there I can only assume
that they have made it for the daily
that's that's it's just how could I not
include it in the daily cancellation
segment
um but that segment apparently I guess
has gone viral on Tick Tock and it's led
to a whole bunch of rebuttal and
reaction videos from the asexual
Community very upset about what I said
about asexuals uh and also the plushie
Enthusiast Community said as well so uh
here's one of those videos
so I heard that all you have to do to
piss off Matt Walsh is to be asexual and
have plushies
so I'm asexual let's meet my pleasures
it's Lotus she her foreign
this is Kaden
uh she they
pomp him
Meadow hey them
Priscilla she her
this is I'm doing this right blushes
than I thought
okay good well so you see I mean clearly
everything I said about you know
asexuals maybe having some issues well
obviously I'm wrong I've been proven
I've been proven totally wrong
listen
uh
the point I made there that I will
reiterate is that you know
if you are defining yourself your your
perceived inability to develop romantic
attractions to other people
um that's not an identity
to be embraced
okay it's it's that's the absence of
something that is your your inability to
experience one of the is something
that's that's Central to The Human
Condition You know the ability to to
experience love and romantic attraction
it's part of what makes us human beings
and so if you perceive yourself to be
unable to do that it's not that's not
your identity now this this emptiness
this absence is not an identity
it's bad enough when people
claim an identity
you know find their identity entirely in
their sexual attractions that's bad
enough because our identity should not
be completely tied up in our sexual
proclivities and attractions that
shouldn't be our whole identity our
whole personality but to make your whole
identity in your whole personality the
lack of that
is even worse
and it's also not something that you
need to just accept
that's part of the problem with making
an identity put it on the flag you know
you have your own acronym in the in the
uh in the LGBT thing you have your own
letter in the acronym uh when you do
that you've just you've you've embraced
and accepted this thing that you don't
need to
because
um there there's obviously some other
issues that are going on that you need
to address
and if you address that then you may
discover that actually although you
perceive yourself to be unable to
develop romantic attractions and to have
that kind of bond with another human
being you perceive that yourself to be
unable to do that you actually are able
to do it but you have to go and get the
help that you need to be able to
experience that aspect of being a human
so I think it's it's a rather
encouraging and uplifting message from
me at least it's as of lifting and
encouraging as it gets okay it's the
best you're gonna get from me
let's get now to the comment section
[Applause]
well people are raving about genucel
skin care Jessica from Huntsville
Alabama says my skin looks so soft and
clear I've seen reduced number of fine
lines and dark spots I have found a new
lifetime product absolutely love it
Jenny cell skincare uses a one-of-a-kind
proprietary flower based develop flower
base developed by the founder and and
pharmacist along with rare Botanical
extracts and Powerful antioxidants for
skin care results that work and this is
all guaranteed gender cell skin care is
uniquely formulated to visibly Target
all visible signs of aging Fine Lines
wrinkles dark spots sagging jawline even
those puffy under under eye bags their
products work for both men and women
plus they're safe for all skin types
you'll see results in 12 hours
guaranteed or your money back you know
as I've told you my talent manager Tesla
uses genucel under eye treatment to help
get rid of the bags under her eyes and
we're constantly always talking about
about that so try genucel's most popular
package for 70 off at genucel.com Walsh
join Millions happy customers who have
already fallen in love with the results
Plus for a limited time get genu cells
probiotic extract moisturizer free with
every most popular package go to
genucel.com Walsh
all right so this is our this is our
last uh day in Florida we've been in
Florida we've been in Palm Beach Florida
the last couple days I was speaking at
the prageru banquet they're Gala in Palm
Beach at the uh The Breakers Resort
which is where we currently are and I've
never been here before it's absurdly
nice and beautiful they don't uh I guess
they built this this building was was
built in a I think in the late 19th
century and you know they don't make
buildings like this anymore it's just a
beautiful Resort it's right on the ocean
uh it's great and um you know oftentimes
when I'm traveling I'll take I'll take a
couple pictures of something I'll send
it to my wife just so she knows she
knows where I am and you know she's
interested in where I am I I decided not
to do that in this case because I didn't
want to rub it in too much uh she's home
with six kids right now so
and you know I was thinking about this
yesterday because I'm sitting in my room
in the morning doing a little bit of
show prep
and I got the windows open overlooking
the ocean can hear the waves crashing
it's beautiful I'm eating The Gourmet
room service breakfast
charge to the Daily wire thank you very
much for that and uh and then my wife
calls me and I can hear the babies
crying in the background and she tells
me that uh that our our three-year-old
had came down with a stomach bug
overnight she was up with a
three-year-old throwing up
and I hear all that commotion I'm
contrasting that with being in my nice
Suite with the ocean and everything and
then
and then she asks me she said well so
that's what happened what's going on
with you
and I just look around I say well it's
it's not good here either I don't want
to go to details but it's bad
don't don't ask me to explain it but it
just is
uh
budgie birdie says
I was laughing so hard at Matt's
experience of shopping with his wife my
husband is the same way we were out one
afternoon and I wanted to stop by Kohl's
and my husband dropped me off and said
he was going home and to call me when I
was done that's a smart move that's a
veteran move by your husband and I still
make the rookie mistake often of uh
saying I'll wait in the car and then
you're waiting in the car for three and
a half hours so uh this is a smart man
it's been around the block a few times
so he says I'll just go home call me
call me sometime this evening whenever
you're done and I'll and I'll come pick
you up smart move um Sarah says the
moment I tuned into the Chris Rock
comedy special I was dying to hear what
Matt's commentary would be hopefully
it's covered and if so buckle up I
haven't watched it yet I know that
there's been a lot of reaction to it and
I guess it's been similar reaction to
Dave Chappelle where this was supposed
to be a comedy special where he's going
after the woke crowd and everything and
I know there are a lot of conservative
people on the right they're applauding
it uh I haven't I haven't listened to I
haven't watched it myself yet
um but but I will
hopefully you know I've said this before
about I appreciate some of what Dave
Chappelle says obviously but I've
actually found his last couple comedy
specials that got all this publicity and
I watched them and I and I thought well
I agree with some of this but I don't
find it that funny it's like it's it
seems like he's he's preaching and I
agree with some of what he's preaching
but it's not as funny as his older stuff
and so
that's a that's something I noticed with
some of these anti-woke comedians there
aren't many of them so maybe we can't
Beggars can't be choosers but
they're saying things that are right but
they've lost some of the of the of the
wit and really you want to have both
um so I don't know if that's the case
for what I'm hoping is that it's
anti-woke and all of that but it's also
really it's actually it is actually
really funny and uh I don't know yet but
I'll I'll watch and find out
um
Justin says I'm so proud to have Matt as
one of us the fish keeping Community is
richer for having him
well I appreciate that Justin this is a
it's a but we are a marginalized
Community ourselves
I'm not sure in what way we're
marginalized but I'll I'll figure that
out
I just know that we are
and Sherry says self-check registers
I've created or allowed a huge theft
problem seems to have seems to happen a
lot and we've seen employees witness it
and do nothing
yeah self-check probably doesn't help
and the employees witness it and do
nothing because they're told that
they're not allowed to do anything
I can remember this even back when I
worked in retail and this is one thing
they told us that if you see anybody
stealing you are not if you try to stop
them you will be fired we'll fire you
for trying to stop them
and so that's why I don't I don't when I
when I see all these videos of people
going in and robbing a place and
throwing items into a you know black
trash bag and walking out with it
and you see the employees just standing
there doing nothing and sometimes the
reaction online will be why are they
doing anything I don't blame them for
not doing anything they're told not to
do anything and if so if they step up
to try to defend their employers bottom
line they'll get fired for it so of
course they're not going to do anything
they don't blame them for that
um I blame the person who's doing the
stealing
and to a certain extent I guess you have
to blame these uh these corporations in
these these stores for having those
policies in the first place they might
want to adjust those policies
um
so that's part of it self-check probably
doesn't help also the masking
now people don't mask nearly as much as
they used to thank God but uh it is it
is this is a connection that's not made
often enough but it is not a coincidence
that this current trend of mass eluding
and mass shoplifting and this kind of
brazen shoplifting that goes on that we
see all the time in the viral videos I
don't think it's a coincidence that this
started to happen
pretty much at the exact moment when
all the customers in all these stores
are wearing masks
some of us warned about that I can
remember sending a tweet out early on
with the masking stuff saying that you
know this is going to leave the
shoplifting got a bunch of customers in
there with their faces hidden
um you're creating opportunities for
shoplifting and I can remember saying
that and being laughed at as if it was
some sort of absurd slippery slope uh
you know extreme hypothetical
it might have been a slippery slope but
it's nothing extreme about it it's like
it's just a matter of connecting the
dots
you know when you when you
tell when you tell customers to hide
their faces and obscure their identity
you are creating more of an of an
incentive and more of a of a Temptation
for stealing more of an opportunity for
stealing and then that's what you end up
with not a big surprise
Jordan Peterson has completed the second
half of his extraordinary 16-part
seminar in the book of Exodus he's
joined by a group of esteemed Scholars
theologians and artists to discuss one
of the most seminal books in the Bible
episode 9 is streaming now on daily wire
plus uh you know we live in a time where
children they don't respect or honor
their parents and that's a horrible
thing for society it's also a broken
commandment as well here's a clip from
Exodus where Jordan is discussing
exactly that they should check it out
okay why should you maybe you have a
terrible father and you have a terrible
mother and you might say well why should
you honor them and why should you honor
the elderly and one answer is going to
be something like well
your destiny is to become elderly and so
if you set up your Society so that the
elderly the Traditions aren't valued and
then you're going to eventually end up
in a situation where you're the
tradition that's not valued so there's
this hint of iterability there right is
that and so and so you might also think
too that that capacity that we have to
honor that which came before us are our
father and our mother is
what is it it's it's an honoring of the
fundamental Spirit of patriarchal and
matriarchal love it's something like
that and it's equivalent to the ethos
that has to bind us together not only
right now but across time it's something
like that the fifth is the fifth is
honor your parents
and your point is entirely accurate and
important it's theoretically on the
wrong tablet because those are all
between man and God and then you have
that
so here's here's how I see it and I I
this is not I don't think it is even
original to me but I haven't heard it
elsewhere but I'm sure it's been said
the first four rest on the fifth and the
second four rest on the tenth
if you honor your father and mother it
is the conduit to God
if you don't have a father on Earth you
won't have a father in Heaven and that
the authority of the parent
Freud even who is an atheist made this
point how you see your father is how you
will see God your your parents are the
conduit especially your father to God
and if you don't have that Authority you
won't have Divine Authority
really interesting great great insights
there and also uh in a you know it's
it's
I was gonna say one of The Commandments
but this is true of all them that have
been forgotten in modern society and and
talking about honoring your parents and
honoring your elders especially in a
culture that worships youth
um is uh is incredibly important that's
one of the one of the many insights you
get from from this episode nine is
available now with new episodes
streaming every week but it's exclusive
for daily wire Plus members also don't
miss out on our full library of Jordan
Peterson content including Dragons
monsters and men vision and Destiny
marriage logos and literacy and uh the
Beyond order tour I don't know how he
manages to create all this content and
uh that's all interesting and insightful
but he does it so join now at
dailywire.com subscribe to watch Exodus
today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
podcast called The Witch Trials of JK
Rowling examines The Life and Times of
the Harry Potter author focusing in
particular on her efforts to defend the
reality of biological sex and the insane
backlash she's received because of that
I haven't listened to the series myself
so I'll just read uh I'll read for you
this very objective explainer by CNN
because they they are explaining what
the series is
is what CNN says and this is not labeled
as an opinion article by the way for
years JK Rowling one of the best-selling
authors of all time has made
inflammatory comments about transgender
people particularly trans women using
dehumanizing language and baselessly
accusing them of harming cisgender women
her words have disappointed Legions of
Harry Potter fans and even the stars who
brought Rowling's book to life now a
podcast called The Witch Trials of JK
Rowling indicates that she'll discuss
the reaction to those anti-trans
comments in addition to discussing her
journey as an author with host Megan
Phelps Roper a high-profile former
member of the anti-lgbtq Westboro
Baptist Church even before its release
the podcast was met with criticism by
lgbtq advocates for seemingly siding
with Rowling based on the title alone
well I'll write that at least CNN
clearly isn't taking sides or maybe they
are but it's okay because Rowling is a
dangerous figure prone to making
outrageous comments such as the claim
that you know biological sex exists and
that women don't have penises the threat
she poses is so severe that the news
media must drop even the pretense of
objectivity when reporting on her though
In fairness these days they also feel
the need to drop the pretense of
objectivity when reporting on literally
anything else
but what sort of threat does Rowling
pose exactly you know they know that
she's a horrible person they know that
she's dangerous they know that she's a
raging bigot
but how do they know this
like why do they think this
and and how is Rowling actually wrong
about anything she said on the subject
of biological sex and transgenderism
these are questions that the media
doesn't spend very much time trying to
Grapple with I mean why bother
explaining why someone is bigoted when
you can simply accuse them of bigotry
and just leave it at that why bother
explaining how they're wrong when you
can again simply accuse them of bigotry
and leave it at that this has been their
General strategy of course uh when it
comes to most people but one Intrepid
reporter Monica Hess of the Washington
Post has decided to tread the the
perilous road that few journalists dare
to go down so she has listened to the
entire Witch Trials podcast uh looking
for specific evidence that Rowling is a
transpho
and she reports her findings in a piece
titled quote listening to The Witch
Trials of JK Rowling is exhausting work
a podcast promised Clarity from Harry
Potter author and how she feels about
trans issues but it falls to the
audience to fact check her
reading a bit from the article it says
listening to The Witch Trials of JK
Rowling is exhausting it's exhausting
because it requires constant vigilance
and it's exhausting because the phrase
constant vigilance I've just realized
entered my own lexicon via Mad Eye Moody
A beloved Harry Potter character because
Rowling is brilliant as a brilliant and
beloved Storyteller who is astonishingly
good at entering lexicons manipulating
language and telling fantasy stories
it's how she became famous it's why
events surrounding rallying these past
few years have felt like a god-awful
mess
so this is a grown adult woman who
writes professionally and yet has
admitted that she learned an extremely
common phrase from a Harry Potter book
in fact she seems to think that this
phrase that has probably appeared in 10
000 books was invented by JK Rowling
which is just her way of confessing that
she's never read any books but the Harry
Potter series
and and that does that does help to put
the anti-ralling Panic into an important
context it's an important thing to
understand that many of Rowling's most
hysterical critics have only ever read
the Harry Potter books along with you
know maybe potentially the Twilight
series so they consider it an
unconscionable betrayal
because they discovered that the author
of the only books they've ever read has
beliefs that differ from their own so
this to them this is like it's like
finding out that your father is living a
secret life with another family across
town they just couldn't process it
they had very very carefully constructed
a bubble for themselves owing only
allowing themselves to be exposed to
opinions and ideas that they already
agree with just to then find out that
the woman who wrote their favorite books
and the only books as far as they're
concerned belongs outside the bubble
she had infiltrated the bubble she was
an intruder
perhaps that's why Monica Hass is so
exhausted
in fact just listening to the podcast is
exhausting she says it's exhausting work
but she's not just exhausted by podcasts
she's also exhausted by reading tweets
later in the piece she writes this quote
Rowling tweets are exhausting they're
exhausting because they require constant
vigilance because they're not screaming
out obvious bigotry Allah I hate trans
people rather they're Whispering a
curated plausible deniability the kind
that purports to be just asking
reasonable questions with simple answers
well I don't doubt that I I do doubt
rather that there are
um any roofers or construction workers
or guys who work on oil rigs reading a
Washington Post article complaining
about a JK Rowling podcast but if there
are I'd love to see how they react to
this woman claiming that her job is
exhausting
because it involves reading tweets and
listening to podcasts
one can just imagine Monica has of the
Washington Post covered in a soot from
from you know working in the Tweet Minds
all day holding her lunch pail punching
out driving home collapsing on the couch
and utter exhaustion muscles aching
barely able to move after an exhausting
day reading JK Rowling tweets
at least that's what she wants you to
imagine
you'll notice that uh that the leftist
they're endlessly complaining about
their own exhaustion and it's not
because they're doing anything
physically demanding or doing anything
at all in general but rather because
it's it's the emotional strain
as they would put the emotional labor of
constantly encountering the traumatic
reality that other people exist
and and they have their own opinions and
beliefs about the world and those
opinions and beliefs sometimes fall
outside of the opinions and beliefs box
that the left has set up for us
this is what exhausts them so much
they are exhausted to discover that they
can't directly control what everyone in
the world thinks and says
but exhausting as this all may be we
still haven't gotten to the point
um Hess has set out to prove that JK
Rowling is bigoted and transphobic
that's that's what she's looking for
she's looking for evidence of that
she knows it's there she can feel it but
she wants she wants to lay eyes on it
does she well it's complicated she
writes quote is JK Rowling transphobic
that's what I was listening to the
podcast to begin with it promised that
Rowling would speak with unprecedented
Candor and depth about the controversy
surrounding her surrounding her from
book bands debates on gender and sex
since 2020 Rowling's status is a
celebrated liberal and literary icon has
taken a nosedive because of tweets and
references that supporters of trans
rights view as transphobic but that
Rowling says are merely trying to
protect women and girls you might have
seen a recent column written by a
British writer named EJ uh Rosetta
Rosetta claimed to have been assigned a
piece called 20 transphobic JK Rowling
quotes were done with but said that
after months of research she hadn't been
able to find a single one rallying
according to Rosetta was saying there
are downsides that I feel should be
discussed not I hate trans people
there truly is the whole issue in a
nutshell if you're a bar for bigotry
requires Rowling to say out loud I hate
trans people then that bar will never be
cleared even if rallying feels that way
I doubt she'd ever say it that way even
conservative pundits know not to say it
that way there is simply nothing to be
strategically gained by uttering such an
obviously prejudiced sentence
so is JK Rowling transphobic then well
Monica goes on and on and on and on back
to the article she says is JK Rowling
transphobic journalism is a business for
sticklers reporters are discouraged from
calling anyone transphobic or homophobic
or racist
but they are that's they're discouraged
from doing that that's that's literally
all they do
um anyway because doing so requires
knowing what's in their hearts well the
only thing we can know with certainty is
what comes out of their mouths so what I
can say is that what comes out of her
mouth or goes onto her Twitter account
has a fuzzy Aura of harmful rhetoric
rallying might indeed believe that she
has transgender friends but take it as a
whole her body is communication on the
issue such as the things she chooses to
retweet in the provocative language she
uses while doing so cumulatively it
sucks
I do not know what is in Rowling's heart
but reading her Twitter feed this is the
overall effect her Twitter feed does not
ask its readers to think it asks them to
fear it creates phobias of trans people
it creates transphobias
okay so translation
all that JK Rowling has ever done when
it comes to this issue is simply assert
the existence of biological reality
Monica Hess cannot coherently explain
why that is bigoted or transphobic uh to
you know to Simply believe in reality
why is that big and she can't explain it
but she's just sure that it is
even if Rally's statements aren't
hateful they still have the fuzzy Aura
of harmful rhetoric there's the aura
there you have to watch out for the
fuzzy Aura she's saying
and this all goes to show of course that
literally anyone who contradicts the
leftist doctrine on any topic especially
this one but not just this one will be
accused of hate and bigotry and branded
as dangerous and as a violent threat to
the lives of marginalized people Etc
this will happen there is no way of
disagreeing with these people there is
no way of presenting your arguments that
will not lead to this conclusion
even if you carefully avoid saying
anything that could reasonably be
construed as bigoted it doesn't matter
because these people are not concerned
about reasons and they are not
reasonable
you can avoid blunt and harsh language
you can do all that but even then you
will still give off the fuzzy Aura of
bigotry
which is all the more reason to never
spend even one second worried about what
labels these people put on you there is
no sense in trying to couch your
rhetoric or soft pedal it
because we are all raging bigots the
moment we walk outside of the box
remember there's the box that they have
set up for us they want everybody in it
if you walk outside of it that's it
our existence is an affront to people
like Monica has
and of course it's also very exhausting
but it's not exhausting for me to say
that uh Monica Hess in the Washington
Post are for all these reasons today
canceled
and I'll do it for uh the show today and
we'll talk to you tomorrow have a great
day Godspeed
[Music]
John Bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less join me and
my co-host Georgia Howe for daily
coverage of all the biggest stories on
morning wire
[Music]
thank you